très heureux de vous revoir dernière
fois que vous avez vu vous étiez pas
bien bien on avait tourné un
documentaire vous avez été une des stars
de Secret Story après vous avez fait les
anges avec votre copain Geoffrey de
l'époque mais vraiment sur médiatisé
parce que vous avez une personnalité
incroyable et au point que tout ça vous
êtes même séparés dans Les Anges de
votre copain tout ça a pris des
proportions énormes vous avez commencé
en souffrir énormément sans trop en
parler et puis un jour vous avez un
accident de voiture assez violent qui a
fait qu'il y a du avoir de la chirurgie
réparatrice exactement les gens vous ont
vu sur les réseaux et vous ont insulté
elle a fait la chirurgie esthétique et
là on a été proches de la tentative de
suicide parce que je me souviens je vous
avais tourné pour une émission et vous
m'aviez dit j'ai jamais été aussi
malheureuse qu'à ce moment là alors
aujourd'hui vous le faites quoi et
comment vous vous sentez en fait avant
de faire la télé j'étais déjà infirmière
infirmière de bloc opératoire donc j'ai
dû me séparer de ce travail pour
m'orienter vers du libéral parce que
j'étais beaucoup trop reconnue au bloc
opératoire et puis aujourd'hui toujours
infirmière pour infirmière libérale mais
je vis toujours les conséquences de la
télé-réalité on reconnaît énormément
déjà je suis toujours reconnu dans la
rue sauf que avant
j'étais aduler aujourd'hui je me fais
insulter tous les noms
de l'insulte pourquoi les gens
t'insultent comme ça
transformation physique
infirmière était les réalités ça ne va
pas ensemble d'accord donc ça vous avez
des patients qui vous le disent que vous
arrivez parfois mais en fait j'ai des
patients qui ont changé d'infirmière
carrément parce qu'en fait il faut
toujours en prouver 10 fois plus qu'une
personne lambda je suis toujours obligée
d'en faire 10 fois plus qu'une
infirmière
suite à un accident malheureusement tu
as dû faire pas mal de chirurgie quand
elle arrive avec sa blouse blanche et
drôle comme ça avec la chirurgie on se
dit qu'est-ce qui se passe que
maintenant elle est magnifique et ma
question aussi c'est que dans les anges
mais on a tous fait des bêtises dans les
anges c'est vrai vous aviez un rôle que
vous entretenez un peu qui était un rôle
un peu la méchante malheureusement
c'est un rôle il faut que les gens le
comprennent
de toute façon mon caractère on va
passer heureusement que j'ai du
caractère parce que sinon je pense que
effectivement je me serais flinguée
retourner dans la lumière plus jamais je
suis encore malheureusement dans la
lumière mais dans la mauvaise lumière à
savoir que je rencontre des gens je ne
sais jamais si les gens sont là pour moi
pour ma notoriété ou parce qu'il pense
que j'ai de l'argent et je peux vous
poser une question assez étonnante quand
même si aujourd'hui vous voulez vraiment
essayer de faire en sorte que plus
personne vous reconnaisse dans la rue et
que la lumière vous a fait du mal je
suis très heureux de vous avoir sur ce
plateau mais il y a entre 6 millions et
15 millions de personnes qui nous
regardent et qui vont forcément vous
reconnaître et remettre un euro dans la
machine dans la dans la ville où vous
habitez c'est parce que c'est important
d'en parler d'accord justement pour les
générations futures pour les filles qui
à l'heure actuelle rêvent de faire de la
télé-réalité faut savoir que ça colle à
la peau toute une vie
revient aujourd'hui et qui prennent des
des golds de commander des anciens et
des nouveaux des All Stars merci tu y
vas ou pas
qui était équilibré qui a pas du tout
souffert de ça c'était une jolie
expérience mais ça et toi
que je voulais juste te faire dire
peut-être à Véronique Mounier c'est que
c'est que moi j'ai pas fait d'émission
scandaleuse quand j'ai arrêté la télé 1
an je vais vous dire la vérité j'en ai
souffert tout d'un coup à 18h j'étais
sur mon canapé et j'avais une vie de mec
de bureau 9h18 heures et j'avais pu
surtout ce petit shoot Kamen la télé qui
rigolo et je m'emmerdais ça mène un
petit chou d'adrénaline on s'ennuie
jamais tu vis l'absence comme un
sentiment
d'échecs
mais c'est pas du tout un échec est-ce
que vous avez des chemins les mecs
excusez-moi
vous comparez mademoiselle et et
Véronique Véronique c'est une
journaliste elle est pharmacienne moi
j'ai bossé avec elle pendant trois mois
c'est comme une journaliste de base
comme moi à l'époque j'imagine et
pensais pas mon image mon machin là tu
es complètement à l'inverse de ça par
définition et c'est pas ta personnalité
c'est le taf que tu faisais
je peux comprendre que Véronique elle
arrête t'étais bah ça change pas sa vie
alors c'est pas une bonne Benoît qui
avait qui a gagné Secret Story 4 mais
quand je dis qu'il a gagné rue de Rivoli
il fait des courses la la boutique pas
réussi la boutique est fermée par la
police tellement il y a une émeute quand
ça s'arrête et que tout d'un coup c'est
comment tu vis ça toi non moi la
différence de notoriété par rapport à
Véronique et mariste c'est-à-dire que
Véronique elle a grandi à notoriété avec
elle ça s'est fait doucement elle ça
s'est fait en deux mois à la gagner
Secret Story millions de téléspectateurs
elle était personne en deux mois elle
était broyée au bout de deux mois parce
que elle pouvait plus sortir avec
beaucoup de dire doucement Marie et sans
aucun talent d'ailleurs
totalement il faut dire ça à mon sens
mais tu as raison de le dire
j'ai une question pour Marie une
question importante parce qu'il y a il y
a deux trois ans il y a eu parce que
c'est très violent la téléréalité et les
buzz qui arrivent derrière sont
généralement toujours des bad buzz et
toi il y a eu une rumeur de décès de
concernant qui a qui a ronflé quasiment
etc
moi j'étais à closer à l'époque on
cherchait par tous les moyens à la
trouver c'était un truc où on se posait
vraiment des questions et je voulais
t'en parler parce que est-ce que c'est
l'une un peu le la goutte d'eau qui a
fait déborder le vase latéraux de la
téléréalité on a tendance à tomber sur
des personnes complètement pour parler
vulgairement cinglés et je suis partie
je suis pas j'ai rencontré ce genre de
personne et pendant 3 ans j'ai vécu
l'enfer donc je n'étais pas décédé mais
ça aurait pu je peux te demander quelque
chose est-ce qu'aujourd'hui tu es entre
guillemets tu es suivi est-ce que tu es
pas antidépresseur mais est-ce que tu as
quelqu'un qui t'aime
je vois une une
mercredi 18h le psychothérapeute pour
essayer oui de vivre un peu mieux tout
ça parce que c'est pas évident parce que
c'est vrai qu'après on a toujours
tendance à tomber sur le même genre de
personne c'est toujours le même genre de
personne qui sont attirées attirés par
des personnalités comme moi